COMMITTEE AND E BANKING SENATO
S RNU WROTE W OP THIWEEKG
PAIN TANS ARFLIOA G ON UE
THAT AT
AKED?
AND COULS. BCI
>> LOOK, WE VE
ECOM
US, BUT THE WAS
HOW FAMILIES ARE EXPERIENCING IT
RIGHT NOW.D THATS BEUS
CHAIOBLEMS ANDECAUSE O
PRICG.
FROM GIANT
AYING MORE ATHE
PUMP, THEY'RE PAYING MORE WHEN
THEY GO  GROCERY STORE
EYORE WHENHEY Y TO HAMBURGER.
SO, IT ISIBILITY OSS, OFRESIDENO
DO T PRICES R .AN.
WE HAVE TO
BUT WE'VE GOT TO -- WE'VE GOT TO
GET UPR ENDS AND
KE.THRICA IADG A RECESSION IF '
THES
>> W WARE IN AN
MIC MOMENT, BUT I  - T E ARE DO.
BACK
THEYOIIONS DE
THEY'RE GOING TO TAKE A BIG
DOLLEXTRA E ARE
ECONOMY -- I THINK WAY TO
DESCRIBE IT, T
WHK.CES TOWE'V
PROFIT-GATHERIBUIN
RE.S CRD  IN THE FIRST 14
MONTHS HE'S BEEN IOF.
UNEMPLOYMENT IS LOW, AND THAT IS
A VERY GOOD .
GDP IS HIGH.
WE'RE STIL GROWTH.
WORRAB
IS ANOTHE
UNKNOWN IN THAT, BUT I THINK
E IT'S LESS CONCERN
OUHE LONG
S HAPPG TO AMERICAN
FAMILIES.
ANWHESS, WHA
OUN DO
ITOW.
WE
FUAMIN LINE AND I
FEET
>> Y PN SOME
ED ECONOMISTS,
OM SUMMERS TO
FURMAN SAY IT IS FACT,HACORE TR
RIBUTINGAC HAT WAS O BI A
INFLATION.
ORTO ERSTAND THE A
INATONE OFM?
SOMEONE TOO BIG, IOPE THEY GO O
OF SMALL BUSINESS OWNE WHOSE
WERE SAVED BECAUSE WE
ACTUALLY PUT INTA SC
I ALSO HOPE THEY WILO  W HAVE
GOTTEN FREE TESTING BECAE
BE SAT THIS ECONOMY R HAT BUSINN
AND TALK TO THMILLIONS OF
LE WHOJUST OVER A YEAR AGO, THE
ING TOE CIMULTIPLE YEARS OGH AT
UNEMPLME.
BUT BECAUSE MOCRAT
E CLEAR.LATO
DEMOCRATS D, WE HAVE THE BASICSH
KNE
DIFFERENCE.THE DEMOCRATS ARE T
YI SET
WE'RE TRYING TO SAVE SMALL
SI
'RR COSTS FO
TO FIG TK  WHO'STAECKOUT LINE AG
BEE THEY DON'T HOU Y TOAND WHAT
DO
PAIN ON AMANILIES AND HE Y OTHET
SMALBUSINESSES.
THAT'S NOT AN
WANT
WER FOR THEMSELVESHE
TO HELP THE AMERICAN
'RE TALKING ABOU
REPUBLICANS.
MI 200 DAYS AWAY.
I WANT TARPAF
E TO DEMOCRATIC DONORS IN SEATT
JUSTS . QUOTE YOU
WHE.ON I'M GETN ROAD INSADAL
DAY-TO-DAY EMERGENCIES IN MY
OFFICE IS MAKING TAS
WHAT WE'VE DONE.OUTING ACCOMPLIS
VI ESENHAT WE'VE DONE,
H.T LESS THAN 20DAYS
FAMILIESE ELECTIONND
OUR JOB,AR
THE MAJORITY, IS LF OF THOSE .
AND THAT MEA
AND THERE IS SO MUCHT WE
CH, FRANKLY, THAT
AMONG  REPUBLICANS AND
WE CEXAM STOP THE
T'AUE
INIGD PROSECE ICE GOUGINLET'S A
WASHINGTON HEAD ON STH WE'RE
STUDENT LDETHE PRENE POWE THATD
TOUCH THE LIVES OF TEN LLNS ACR
THERE IS SO .E DO IEREXT
20E GOING  B.
THIS IS WHATCY THEEOPLE, WHAT
WEEED TO GET
RK DONE. IYOT, WLOSE COL OF CO?
>>EAH, IO AL TROUBLE IF WEON
RATS ARE
WORKING AND WE CAN'T JUST RESTNT
E DONE.
WE NEED TO B
THERE AR TCAN  E DO ANSTILL EDT.
WE DTH W.
ESSEPEWEE RTTO
LTURE WARS.
TH NHE P
INIR LIVES.
AS DEMOCRATS IS TO HELP
HARD AMERICANS.
AN C
WE CAN MAKE GOVERNMENT N BILLIOT
F GIANTORPORATIONS.
WE COULD ACTUALLY MA IT WORK ERT
SENATOR, THE BIDEN
ADNISTRATION IIN
WHAT'S KNOWN AS TITL42,
TRUMP-ERRU, MAKING IT EAURRAS
TH.DER. G
BUT ALMOST AF
OW
PRRNS ABOUT TH.ORT LIFTING TITLO
WHATS YOUR PN E KELY SURGE I
D NF WILL
HUMANELY?
DP US.E BIDEMIS SNT WITES
PUPLANS IN PLACEO AL
WITH PEOPLE WHKI
AMNESTY AND HUMANITARIAN RELIE B
N D IMMIGRATN .'SOM
DEMOCRATS ARE ON BOARD
E EED TOE IN THAUGH.
THAT'S W WE NEED TO MAKE
SIGNIC.
>> PRESIDENT BID JT UNVEILED
HEILLIONACKAGE TO
UKRAINE
PROGRAM.A E AVY ARLL
APPROVFAR.T D ALMONEY TH
ATNG
URN TH COMING
WEEK?T DEKS I RAINE, EITHER MITA
HUMANITARIAN RELIEF, I WIL
SUPPORT HIM IN THAT, AND IL  DE
WILL.
>> BEFOR SKBO "THE NEW RK TIMES
EY REVEALEW O FROM
HO LEARTE MEDIATELY FOLLOWIN
STEN TO WHAT HE SAIDO  CALLS.W
REPORTED M SOME
RESPONSIBILI FORT HAPPEND WE N A
>> THE DSSDID HAVE
PASS. WRECOMMENDATIS
>> YOU HNOT SANGOW
WHAT'S YOU?
EVTRAITOTHIS I IS REALLY THEERV
ICAN PUBLIAN
ELSE IN ATE. UNDAND THAT WRONG
N ATTEMPT TO
DIFFERETE OF NG THEIR ENERGY O
IS